تصعيده جديد قد تشهده باكستان والسبب ان
الحكومه تدرس حظر حركه انصاف وهي حزب رئيس
الوزراء السابق عمران خان وزير الدفاع
الباكستاني عاصف خواجه قال في بيان له ان
الحكومه تدرس فرض حظر على حركه انصاف بعد
احداث التاسع من مايو والتي قام فيها
مناصروخان باضراب النار باضراب النار في
المباني الحكوميه
والمركبات وشن هجمات على الشرطه
والعسكريين والمنشات احتجاجا على اعتقال
رئيس الوزراء السابق
ومحاكمته اما عن تزاعيات المحتمله في حال
اصدر قرار حظر الحزب او اصدر هذا القرار
فذلك يعني توترا وتصعيدا كبيرا يحتمل ان
يخرج عن الحزب او انصاره وفقا لمقربين او
يحتمل ان يخرج عن كل من ينتمون الى الحزب
وفقا من مقربين من خان كما ان حظر يحتاج
لتجاوز قوانين ومواد دستوريه لان حركه
انصاف حزب سياسي مسجل ومرخص ويخوض
الانتخابات وفقا لحمايه الدستور
الباكستاني ويستحيل حظر هذا الحزب او اي
حزب الا بحكم من المحكمه العليا او بتعديل
من التعديل الدستوري يقره البرلمان وهذا
ما قد تلجا اليه الحكومه الباكستانيه
الحاليه ويعد مشاهدينا عمران خان هو رئيس
الوزراء الوحيد في تاريخ باكستان الذي تمت
الاطاحه به من خلال التصويت بحجب الثقه
حيث يواجه عدد كبير من القضايا المرفوعه
ضده طبعا من بينها الارهاب وغسيل الاموال
والتامر على الدوله وغيرها من التحم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات